allora ragazzi facciamo questo tentativo
estremo visto che è cambiato anche
vestiti cupido che sta registrando
questa cosa in un altro giorno potevo
provare a fare meta meta video oggi
provando a giocare una partita online
quindi ma anche l'altra online però con
gente a caso sono solo io imposto le
ragazze tasti che sta roba
ok
tix light peak life sono morti in tre
tra l'altro in ammazzato uno che è
successo e così ne elettrica nessuno
dice nulla un allertato ma come si fa a
giocare online sto gioco come si fa a
giocare online a sta roba mannaia sono
l'unico che parla agli atti non parla
nessuno parla che mi ha votato anna
subito ad uccidere ma vediamo io sono a
sinistra perché c'era solo un tizio a
sinistra e ragazzi parte che c'è il fix
l'aisla fare 15 che non è passata dai su
ok
qualcuno come perfetto allora diamo a
sinistra vediamo se c'è ancora qualcuno
aspetta aspetta aspetta tracanna morta
report aw self report ragazzi ma nessuno
fa e dice un cave sono ma come si faccia
avere con questi e per ragazzi erano
quasi ingiocabile ingiocabile online è
ingiocabile nessuno dice niente nessuno
parla nessuno scrive fate qualcosa
parlate esatto è dio nessuno parla e li
ammazzano tutti da sola a meno che non
mi votate completamente a casa e non vi
meritereste la vittoria ma fa niente se
non parla non fanno niente
guarda cos'è cos'è la gente non gioca
chi mi ha votato il viola ammazzano
viola quanti ne mancano raga che non lo
so
facciamo sabotaggio due no non posso
sabotare ancora
ok ne manca uno sabotaggio 2 sabato lo 2
ho vinto io che avevo due lombar se ho
vinto teoricamente ho fatto fuori tutti
che scarso id online anzi guarda sto qua
a casa appena arriva qualcuno lo faccio
fuori lo secco moriranno eccolo qua ma
questa bella horeca complimenti siete
competitivi bravissimi bravi ma i boys
new ways of a long as
sono molto contento di giocare a
prendermi un casco i ragazzi e veglioni
chiuderci innanzi tutto qua dentro in
centro a qualcuno la massa e poi vado 20
vado lens ebrei dove dove solo non c'è
nessuno nessuno gioca buddy però a farlo
fuori mercato la sua teoria sì
completamente random
vediamo se ho fatto un po di bardi che
stava fermo al centro totale ok allora
lì a fette ria proprio il centro non
siede di fronte a tutti morto patti
ragan di chi ha coraggio che noi e
pulita l'ho seguita male non ha visto
secondo me si può però ora si fermano
paperino
io mi fido io mi fido abbastanza di
dediche noia poi gli altri nostro
eravamo insieme io ho fatto set col
quindi fa ma vediamo dopo no sarebbe
magico per ora andiamo e fatto se va
bene
raga è stata una bella famiglia può
rischiosa perché al centro passano tutti
quindi sono stato veramente bene rario
però funzionato anche se fini ha fatto i
complimenti
effettivamente la mega rischio e lo star
o andiamo di sotto allora una buona
tattica potrebbe essere quella di di
chiudere le porte per omar sta qua mar
ci sta questa qua porca vacca chi da un
caffé siria non si riesca a far fuori
qualcuno
march ok ok
faccio finta di fare tasche qua sopra
signori vorrei dare un suggerimento per
la partita non andate via caffetteria
perché letale non hanno messo nel caffè
ma non prendete da me e dai nat non
iniziare ma posso dire una cosa questo è
un serial killer della gente fk perché
sono blu impostare uccidete che noia io
non segnato più corpi a priori
arrangiatevi ciao è ormai è mafia certo
adesso arriva ritardissimo custodiscono
ma come fanno qua cos'è sta roba cosa
vedo ma cosa sto vedendo mi spiegate
cosa state facendo in mezzo
[Musica]
brava brava brava che noia brava che
noia brava brava brava che noia brava si
gioca così che mi state parlando giusto
sempre questo però sempre lui ma di fare
il titolo solo uccisione caffetteria ok
di più perché velatamente il prossimo
facciamo solo chi la security quando
sono brutto incredibile ma io non amo il
e viceversa non renda manco il tempo di
tornare o che ero lì ma non presenta
caffetteria ammazzo signori questa era
un tentativo di partita online
mamma mia che scarso e di della morte
perché se giochi tanto con gli amici mi
capisci tattiche robe quando giochi
online e samele gioca con birilli i
ragazzi spero vi sia piaciuto cda la
prosecuzione di among us senza così
discrete e decidiamo come sempre ha
proseguito bella ragazzi
[Musica]